this is a scene from the amazing
spider-man this is from marvel's luke
cage
and this is a scene from joker notice
something similar they're all shot in
the exact same place the 12th avenue
underpass in harlem when you stand
underneath riverside drive i mean it is
like the classic abandoned new york
location that everybody always wants the
underpass is known for its viaduct an
arching structure with a grand juror
filmmakers are drawn to it gets a lot of
play because it is just a really
visually captivating space it gives this
basically cascading overhang of just
metal work this is just one of several
new york filming locations you see
pop-up again and again in shows and
movies we spoke with five location
scouts to find out why these spots are
in such high demand
if you look closely at the prison scenes
in a bunch of new york movies you'll see
these were all filmed at arthur kill
correctional facility this
decommissioned prison in staten island
has everything you could ever need for a
jail or prison scene from the barbed
wire and guard tower in front to real
cells inside it also comes with a lot of
space with 70 acres of grounds and these
long stretches of hallway that helps for
choreographing action sequences it's
that kind of facility and aren't that
many that lends itself to having these
really long unbroken takes like
daredevil season 3 12 or 13 minutes
uncut just moving through the entire
space down the hallways past the cells
out to the front door the location is
surprisingly versatile multiple cell
blocks can look like different prisons
if you didn't want to just be at one
there are sections that could work as a
hospital and it's great because let's
say you have to marry two locations
together and those scenes don't fill a
full day you can combine them into one
day and film it there for example the
facility's giant parking lot was even
dressed up as afghanistan for the code
dramatic mystery scenes villain
face-offs and wild car stunts have all
used this very backdrop the brooklyn
navy yard a vestige of industrial new
york brooklyn once had a busy industrial
waterfront but over the past few decades
high-rise apartment complexes and office
buildings have moved in and turned the
former manufacturing hub much more
residential that's why scouts return
again and again to this shipyard where
70 000 people once worked before it
closed down in 1966
when everything is emptied out the
abandoned docks and hulking warehouses
can create an ominous look exactly what
crime shows are after you want that like
you know really industrial or oh no
somebody's getting murdered on the docks
at night great place to go to bodies
have been dumped at this dry dock in
multiple shows the amount of open space
makes it possible to execute wild stunts
like when daredevil blew up a boat on
the docks the end of the first john wick
movie there was a car chase and then a
car like crashed into this dry dock like
you know dropped into it
many filmmakers focus on the grit of the
city but some scenes call for a more
buttoned-up new york setting like this
one that pops up again and again in
scenes involving business or government
meetings manhattan has plenty of office
spaces but many are on extremely high
floors which means the lighting very
much depends on the sky rather than
relying on natural light from the
windows the filmmakers need to control
the lighting then you can basically
shoot it any which way you want and have
it
look always the same but the higher the
office spaces are the more difficult to
get lights into that's what makes this
spot prime it's an office on the third
floor of the brooklyn public library
with big windows that crews can pass
lights through and because it's on a
reachable floor they can do it without
getting a big condor lift involved the
office also has a versatile mid-century
design that can work across many decades
from modern business dramas like
billions to period pieces like the
marvelous mrs maisel
a lot of the most famous subway scenes
are shot at one specific station hoyt
schermerhorn
the reason this spot is so popular well
filming authentic subway scenes comes
with huge challenges sometimes you know
you're at the whim of the mta and things
can change we had that happen for in the
heights they had to reroute their trash
trains and essentially their trash
trains had to come through our set crews
are less likely to run into these
logistical problems if they film at
tracks that are no longer in use like
the one at hoyt schermerhorn it's a
working station but with one deactivated
platform among three active ones it's a
place where we know we can film during
regular business hours signage can turn
it into basically any other subway stop
like in this scene from coming to
america when lisa enters the station
it's labeled as van wyck boulevard but
if you look closely you'll see it's
actually hoyt the giveaway is those blue
and yellow tiles with a circled l in the
middle remnants of what was once one of
brooklyn's biggest department stores
losers which stood where hoyt does today
then when lisa exits the train the
station's labeled sutfin but this was
also filmed at hoyt
recognize this bar it's appeared in
everything from tv shows like gotham to
movies like the kitchen for scenes set
in dive bars and shadowy back rooms
directors like martin scorsese often
want the real deal brooklyn's irish
haven has kept its tile floors and wood
paneling mostly unchanged since 1964.
when it was a favorite spot for iron
workers to unwind after work there's a
pool table dartboard and jukebox it has
also just this great seasoned new york
look to it you don't have to change too
much when you go there the no frills
exterior and dimly lit interior are well
suited to gritty settings like gotham
and the classically divey setting can
stand in for other cities too not just
new york the bar and pool table are
famous for these scenes in the boston
set the departed
when you see new york in a movie you
might see a scene like this
or this
a dark seedy alleyway filled with
graffiti shuttered apartment windows and
old fire escapes but in reality new york
doesn't really have alleyways which
means dozens of famous scenes have been
filmed in this exact spot to get that
gritty look
one reason so many scripts call for new
york scenes to take place in alleys is
well hollywood the writing for most
projects takes place in la when you go
to la there's alleys everywhere new york
was designed according to the grid
system with little to no space for
alleys the real estate is so valuable
that we just didn't leave space for it
if they're envisioning l.a alleys
probably not going to find it but there
are other types of alleys that are
smaller and tighter like cortland alley
which might be the most used filming
location in all of manhattan that is an
alley that gives you just about
everything it's fire escapes it's
graffiti many of the apartment windows
have these big decades-old shutters
which adds to the alleys aesthetic crews
can put lights inside the windows of the
apartments above i've paid people in the
same apartment buildings for lighting
positions looking in the same exact
spots that
teenage mutant ninja turtles shot in as
well the location's use goes beyond just
gritty scenes take this wholesome scene
in annie which eric worked on the team
used cortland alley to create a path for
this chase sequence adding trash and
boxes as obstacles little nooks in the
alleyway served as spots for the dog
trainers to hide during filming since
cortland alley is owned by the city it's
cheaper to film there as it's one of the
very few actual public alleys it gets
used all the time so much that sometimes
it's put in what's called the hot zone
in new york city when something's been
filmed too much and the residents are
unhappy with the impact it has the
mayor's office will put something on the
hot zone and that means that there's a
sort of a moratorium on filming until
they take it off there
portland alley has stayed looking more
or less the same for decades but in much
of new york things are always changing
these steps in joker they were actually
the director's second choice todd
phillips initially requested this
menacing set of stairs from american
gangster and when i went to go visit it
it had gotten
a whole makeover brand new concrete
little cute trees it had been power
washed of all of its graffiti and kind
of grit after visiting 25 to 30
different step streets aaron tracked
down this one which had exactly what
they were looking for it brought drama
in terms of the length and steepness of
the stairs kind of confined and narrow
it hit all the marks and it had that
great view just off from the top looking
into the city that that really worked
for us as well
the spot became instantly iconic showing
that while the face of the city is
always changing new york will always be
a great place to shoot movies